[Music]
it is seven o'clock good to see you this
morning it may well be april fool's day
but for millions waking up across the
country the impact of the cost of living
crisis is no laughing matter an
unprecedented rise in the energy cap
means the number of people in fuel
stress
has doubled overnight
add in the national insurance types
staggering inflation and of course those
record fuel prices
and it is not hard to see why living
standards have fallen to the lowest
level since the 1950s the chancellor has
introduced some measures to soften the
blow but
will there be enough i'll shortly be
joined by the policing minister kit
malthouse i'll then be asking the labour
leader secure stamina how he would
tackle the crisis and of course a little
later this hour ukraine's deputy health
minister is on the show as the
humanitarian crisis there deepens
it is friday the 1st of april
breaking point the biggest jump in
energy bills ever with a warning of
worse to come
turning off the taps russia vows to cut
europe's gas supply today unless it's
paid for in rubles
france and germany reject the demand
calling it blackmail
evacuating mario paul another attempt to
get thousands out of the besieged city
today as peace talks resume
backtracking on a u-turn the government
says it will ban gay conversion therapy
no symptoms no test the end of free
covered lateral flow testing for most
people in england
the slap heard around the world the
oscars producer says police were
prepared to arrest will smith on the
night
and i'm live in doha where the
controversies continue but it is time
for the world cup final draw wales and
scotland could still qualify and
southgate says england could win it if
they are close to perfect
also on the programme ahead of world's
autism day i'll be speaking to the
former senior raf officer about the film
he produced on how nature has helped his
severely autistic brother
no no
[Music]
and i'll be joined by the lead singer of
10cc as the legendary band prepare to
embark on their ultimate greatest hits
tour
[Music]
morning all
it is the biggest jump in household fuel
bills in living memory dealing a massive
blow to millions of families already
struggling with the soaring cost of
living from today the energy oh sorry
the energy price cap will rise
significantly which means the number of
people in fuel stress has doubled to 5
million
and there are warnings of worse to come
when bills start to reflect the effects
of the war in ukraine let's just take a
quick look at the numbers the price cap
well it's increasing by 54
that is on average a rise of 693 pounds
per year meaning the typical household
bill jumps from 1277
to
1971 pounds
it's estimated this will have an effect
on around 22 million households
the price increase well it's been
largely driven by the cost of wholesale
energy which of course has risen sharply
but it's not just energy bills national
insurance contributions are also going
up by 1.25 points this month
and the rate of inflation expected to
reach a 40-year high of 8.7 percent
uh let's get the view from the
government now on the cost of living
crisis the minister for policing kit
malthouse joins us once again on the
program minister it's good to see you
this morning and um
the reason i say so whenever we have
chatted in the past you know you
compared to some of your colleagues have
always been prepared to be quite candid
about what is going on and at a moment
like this i think the public deserves a
little bit of candor
how bad are things about to get for a
large number of britons
well obviously as as you quite rightly
say it's very tough at the moment
we completely acknowledge that the the
combination of factors that you outlined
uh in your run-up to this
uh interview has meant that prices are
rising significantly energy prices in
particular driven by a variety of
factors post-pandemic the war in ukraine
you know other kind of global factors
outside of our immediate uh control and
it is tough uh you know for those of us
who have a a smart meter as as we do
here in my house you know we can see how
much it's costing us on an hourly basis
and it is uh
not happy reading um having said that uh
obviously uh notwithstanding the the
rise in the national insurance uh
threshold that you um uh the rise in the
national insurance rate that you just
outlined there are other measures that
the chancellor's taken to try and help
with some of the cost of living
problems so you know the cut in fuel
duty obviously the national insurance
threshold will be raised from july
that's worth about 300 quid a year to
sort of 30 million working people across
the country we've got this household
support fund now a billion pounds that's
targeting those in real need um across
the whole of england and wales and then
of course the other thing to bear in
mind that that happens today of course
is the national living wage rises by six
point six percent to nine pounds fifty
which is the largest rise i think uh uh
for some time and that should be about a
thousand pounds a year uh for a
full-time worker so while it is tough
obviously the chancellor's trying to do
his best to ameliorate the challenge
although we can't go all the way and
ameliorate at all i'm afraid
no no but some would question why
a lot of the assistance appears to have
been targeted at those who are perhaps
not most in need i mean the estimates
vary but a kind of a ballpark figure
appears to be like one in three pounds
announced by the chancellor in the
spring statement going to the bottom
half of the income distribution
why are we spending two out of three on
the top half
well i'm not sure would necessarily uh
characterize it that way we are
targeting
lots of the assistance at people at the
lower end of the wage distribution so
whether that's the rise of the national
living wages household support fund
billion pounds now being targeted and
then of course raising the national
insurance threshold uh helps them too
and don't forget uh the change in the
universal credit taper for those who are
in receipt of universal credit but also
working that's worth about a thousand
pounds a year so when you take it in the
round you know i think you'll find it is
skewed towards the bottom end albeit we
want to try and help as many people as
possible within the financial
constraints that we've got it's worth
remembering as well of course that one
of the biggest
helps is to be in work and obviously uh
levels of employment are at an all-time
high at the moment
you're talking about payroll presumably
you're not talking about numbers and
what because we're comparing numbers and
numbers actually but this is a mistake
that the government has repeatedly made
you know for whatever purpose but
actually if we're talking about the
numbers of people in work at the moment
we're talking several hundred thousand
fewer than they were at the start of the
pandemics like let's just part that for
a second what specifically though are we
doing for those people who are not
earning a wage all those people who are
on such low incomes that they are still
in receipt of universal credit we have
seen a small percentage point rise in
universal credit but one which will i'm
sure you will agree be utterly dwarfed
by the inflation which we will
experience this year
well obviously the the key targeting
mechanism is this household support fund
you know we had it at half a billion
pounds was very successful local
authorities targeting that money at
those most in need at the lower end of
the economic uh scale we've doubled that
now to a billion pounds and obviously
hopefully
we have got a high number of vacancies
in the economy hopefully they can work
with their
department of work and pensions work
coaches to get into work and benefit
from that change in the taper you know
we want to see everybody what if they
don't what if they can't find a job and
that's what we're trying to do
but what what if they can't find a job i
mean on the one hand we're saying you
know we're seeing almost record
employment you also say just a moment
ago there are lots of job vacancies out
there so i'm slightly confused but for
those people who do not have a job right
now or for example a single mother
working 20 hours a week on receipts of
universal credit she will be poured her
off as a result of the changes made by
the chancellor
well as i say if she's struggling uh
then there's the household support fund
that she can look to obviously
which is finite
it is finite but it's very targeted you
know it's a billion pounds that's being
targeted and as we move into the to the
rest of the year obviously the
chancellor is going to monitor the
situation very closely um and think
about what more we may be able to do to
help and he signaled that in the past
look neil you are quite right we are we
are facing a a very difficult global
situation here driven by
external factors outside the country at
the same time we're facing a very
challenging financial situation
internally having spent you know
billions and millions of pounds getting
ourselves through the pandemic in in
good shape what we're trying to do is
balance that situation help as many
people as we can with what we
acknowledge is a very tough uh situation
at the moment and then hope that over
time things will improve from an
inflation and a fuel price point of view
and we can get back onto the onto the
path to prosperity
when the chancellor describes the policy
initiatives that he's brought forward as
progressive what does he mean by that i
just want to focus for a second on on
the council tax rebate i will be in
receipt of that you may well be in
receipt of that i'm just going to gently
suggest that if a breakfast television
news presenter is in receipt of funding
it's not a progressive policy i don't
need it
well
i mean obviously everybody is suffering
from the the fuel price uh uh rise uh
lots of people need i'm not assistance
yeah but we are we also uh pumping the
the council tax bill into people at band
a uh in particular and then grading it
over time so we're trying to give
now a kind of balanced package
of assistance across the whole of the
economy right now whether that is
targeting money at people who are really
struggling through the household support
fund or providing widespread relief
through the raise in the national
insurance threshold we're trying to give
a balanced package across the whole of
the economy because people are
struggling different ways you know if
you are a
family of uh uh two parents with
children you've got significant extra
costs compared to a single person living
alone so we need to make sure that we
have a
very balanced package that gives as much
assistance as we can within the
constraints that we've got
let's take just a couple of the measures
we were talking about there i mean
national insurance i get it if you
expand at the bottom that does mean
fewer people are paying tax but what of
those who aren't at that threshold point
already chancellor made an awful lot
about the cut and fuel duty when he was
at the dispatch box again if you look at
the numbers those at the very bottom end
55
of the bottom demographic don't drive
these measures do not help i mean are
you are you entirely confident
that the chancellor a man who on a
treasury organized photo opportunity
couldn't work out how to pay for petrol
at the pump
are you in any way confident that this
is a man who genuinely knows what it is
like to be counting the pennies in your
pocket
i am yes and i think that's unfair on
him you've got to remember the great
advantage uh of our system
is that all of us as mps are anchored in
our constituencies right and we sit down
as i will be later today in a
constituency surgery and we deal with
our our constituents on a daily basis
with the very
huge variety of issues and problems that
we had so notwithstanding our own
particular situation financially
obviously we have you know heavy
exposure to how everybody across the
whole of the of course of course i'm
talking about this individual ability to
empathize with people at the bottom end
of society i mean this this is a
chancellor that thought there was a
debate about whether or not to give poor
kids food during the summer holidays
well as i say i think that's unfair the
chancellor is trying to do a very
difficult thing which is to balance the
requirements of the british people for
assistance at a time of need against the
long-term financial health of the whole
country right we we've just come through
a pandemic where we had to spend 400
billion plus to keep the economy on
track that work that he did has kept
hundreds of thousands if not millions of
people
in work and kept you know them going uh
through one of the most difficult things
we've faced in this country since the
second world war that was a massively
challenging job and he pulled it off uh
with enormous skill and dexterity of
course he's in touch with the problems
of the british people and that's why we
brought in the measures work that we've
had but as he's said uh just to think
yesterday right that the constraints of
the national economy mean that we can't
solve every problem we have to monitor
the situation everyone understands that
everyone understands that i'm sorry
financially as we can to help as many
people as we can okay then why on earth
then are we starting today to charge
people for lateral flow tests we've both
conceded a moment ago that genuinely
people are literally counting the
pennies in their pockets if it is a
toss-up between spending two pounds in
food for your kids or two pounds in a
lateral flow test we both know which way
people's priorities will go why are we
making people right now choose between
putting food in their kids belly and
working out whether or not they've got
covert
well that's because obviously we're
moving to a situation as the prime
minister's outline where we we have to
now live with covet um and deal with the
commissions are running as high as
they've been this year minister yeah i
know i understand that i just had it
myself a couple of weeks ago um as as
the rest of my family so we've had
impact at home too um look we're moving
towards living with govid uh the lateral
flow test has got an absolute fortune um
uh every month uh we believe now that we
can sort of get on with normalizing
society not withstanding the rise in
infections that we've seen i'm not
asking you to pay for everyone i'm not
asking you to pay for my for my lateral
flow test i'm lucky enough to work for a
company that provides them i'm asking
you to perhaps provide them i don't know
to people on universal credit
well as i say the the decision has been
made at the department of health the
cost of it didn't justify the effect
ongoing that we're learning to live with
covid obviously we're now rolling out as
you know the fourth booster uh to those
people most vulnerable um so we we now
have to live with this uh disease i'm
afraid and that means that free lateral
flows are coming to an end given the
cost benefit analysis i guess that the
treasury has done
i i do want to ask just as as we wrap up
about the energy strategy the depending
energy strategy
when will that be published i understand
that everyone in government has an
absolute ton on their plate at the
moment but the simple truth of the
matter is you are wrestling with the
energy strategy back when boris johnson
became prime minister when greg clark
was the business and energy secretary
there was a debate ongoing then about
nuclear power and how to fund it when
are we going to get the detail on this
well as i understand it there's
obviously intensive conversations going
on particularly accelerated in the light
of the of the ukraine
exacerbation if you like of the global
energy situation and and i think that
strategy will be appearing i gather
shortly um it's obviously a big and
extensive uh document that needs
consideration and there's some big
financial strategic decisions that need
to be made so i'm not surprised that
it's taking just a little bit more time
than it was anticipated um hopefully
it'll be next week but let's see
is this as it's been pretty widely
reported because the prime minister and
the chancellor has on so many issues at
the moment cannot come to agreement on
nuclear power well i'm not close to the
conversation to be honest with you but i
don't know but given the scale of the
strategic decisions that are being made
i hope the british people would want
their politicians to be really chewing
on this issue
very extensively and seriously and
having intensive discussions about what
the right track is for the future i
think it's now accepted uh that
governments of previous generations
possibly made an error in not investing
in nuclear but these are huge
investments required for the future of
our power and fuel security and so it's
right that we take time to to just get
the decisions correct
okay it's great to have you on the
program this morning really appreciate
your
time well we have now heard from the
government so might as well get the
opposition's view uh of everything uh
let's speak now to the leader of the
labour party sir starmar joining us uh
from a little bit further north secure
lovely to see you this morning um i hope
you were able just to listen into to a
little of what we were hearing from from
the government this morning in terms of
their response to the cost of living
crisis but can we be brutally honest no
matter whether it's a conservative prime
minister a labour prime minister monster
raving looney prime minister in downing
street at the moment no politician can
act to ameliorate all of the effects of
the cost of living crisis
well of course it's a difficult
situation i think we all appreciate that
but you know today is a really
significant and worrying day
for millions of people because their
energy bills are going to go up by
hundreds of pounds and i've spoken to
people across the country
particularly those who are struggling
financially and they're really worried
about tossing and turning in their beds
about how they're going to pay for this
what we've said as the labour party is
look oil and gas companies in the north
sea have made more profit than they
expected because global prices have been
high therefore we should have a windfall
tax on that and use it to reduce those
energy bills by up to 600 pounds for
those that need it most so there's a
very practical plan on the table the
only plan on the table quite frankly
we've also said of all the times for the
government to decide to impose more tax
in national insurance now is the wrong
time it's the wrong tax it's the wrong
time and so
um i think
most people
are clear that when
you know the government really needed to
step up in that spring statement last
week
they failed to do so and their response
is frankly pathetic on a very very
difficult day for millions and millions
of people energy bills going up
for you know more than we've ever seen
on record um you know people are really
struggling and i just don't think the
government gets it
yeah
just just though on the windfall tax
plan i mean this isn't the problem yeah
indeed it was identified by pat mcfadden
your colleague when he was speaking to
me last week you can do it once so your
words are really important right now you
haven't said it in this interview but
you have said previously the windfall
tax plan would all but eliminate the
energy price rise for low-income
families pensioners and middle-income
families i mean
that might be true
now but it won't be true later on this
year when we see another set of price
rises
look it is a one-off tax um it's a
windfall tax but it would deal with the
immediate crisis and people waking up
today
are asking the question
uh is there a plan on the table to deal
with the problem i've got right now
which is this rise in my prices uh
energy costs of hundreds of pounds and
they're seeing nothing from the
government the government says well you
can have a loan starting in october of
about two hundred pounds so six
my point is simply this yeah that the
windfall tanks that you're proposing
will give a break of a hunt a few
hundred pounds right now which will
frankly by my looking at the numbers be
utterly wiped out by the price rise that
we're all expecting come october
well there are two answers to that the
first is obviously there's got to be a
wide and medium a long-term strategy and
that's why we set out our energy
strategy last week which included
turbocharging renewables
fast-forwarding on nuclear power but
importantly and significantly also
a project um to insulate homes and make
them warmer and i saw i'm up in
manchester at the moment
last week i was in kirkleese and i saw
for myself council houses that have
already gone through that process of
insulation and i met the residents there
their bills are already very very low
because of that insulation program led
by a labour council that's the sort of
medium to long-term measure we need so
the labour party says we've got a plan
for dealing with the immediate crisis uh
which is facing people today but we've
also got a plan for the longer term the
other thing i would add of course is
that you know as global prices stay high
that profit for the oil and gas
companies will be even higher probably
by the autumn than it is now but
contrast the labor party that's got a
practical plan to reduce bills now and
the government's pathetic response they
just don't get it they don't realize how
hard people are struggling just at the
moment
for a variety of reasons
associated with the government's plan to
increase tax and do nothing about these
energy prices okay but what intel okay
in terms then of benefits why does
labour not agree with with plenty of
those working uh you know ngos at the
moment that you know benefits should not
be raised in line with inflation
well i think that that is something we
should look at because uh benefits have
fallen behind what what people wanted
from the government last week in that
spring state no no no no no no second
i'm asking you i'm asking you would you
could you as a point of principle
i'm asking for a policy commitment here
would you increase in line with
inflation because if you don't people on
benefits experience a real terms cut in
the amount amount of money that they
have
yeah i think we've got to look at it for
that very reason because otherwise
people fall behind that's what we wanted
to see from the government last week
that's what we didn't see from the
government last week frankly if the
government put a package on the table
that parliament could agree we could get
on with this but the government just
doesn't get the scale of the problem for
millions of millions of people
total elections coming up in five weeks
time also
and if people want to send a message to
the government to say um britain
deserves better than this your response
to the cost of living crisis is pathetic
this is the chance to do it what labor
is saying we've got a plan on the table
and we're we're on your side we
understand we take your worries
seriously
what about the minimum wage the rise
we're seeing today is is apparently the
third largest rise since the crash of
2008 some people are asking why it's not
the largest you know price the increase
in minimum wage that we've seen since
since 2008 it wasn't that long ago that
andy mcdonald resigned from the front
bench because you wouldn't agree to a
minimum wage of 15 pounds an hour i mean
isn't that something that the labour
party could as a progressive party get
behind right now that would have an
immediate effect
on the quality of life for many many
people
yeah what we put on the table at our
conference was an increase in the
minimum wage to
about 10 pounds as part of a package of
employment rights day one rights and i
can tell you this had that package been
in place had you had a labor government
taking seriously the security of people
at work you would not have had the
scandal of pno sucking 800 people in the
awful way that we they did the
government was on notice about that not
just because they had the memo the night
before the 800 were made redundant but
also because two years ago
we were saying to them if you don't act
on this minimum wage for seafarers
a company in the end is going to crash
through the gate and reduce
their replace their workforce with
agency workers on less than the minimum
wage that's exactly what has happened
two years ago the government said oh we
acknowledge that's a problem we'll look
at it they did nothing pno crashed
through the gate 800 people lost their
jobs
do you generally think british inflation
that is is huge
so do you generally believe the british
public are looking at what labour is
offering in contrast to the government
at the moment i i'm thinking this is a
radical party this is a party with big
ideas an increase to roughly 10 pounds
and kind of
for the for the minimum wage a one-off
windfall tax that would cover most of
your price increases right now but
nothing for later on in the year
where's the invention
what i want people to
do is to look at the labour party and
see a party that understands their
worries that takes them
seriously and is prepared to put
practical plans on the paper on the
table people don't want a revolution
they do want to know how am i going to
pay my energy bill which has just gone
up today by hundreds of pounds we're
putting a practical plan on the paper on
the table it says for those that need it
most um you ask oil and gas companies
who have made more profit than they were
expecting to make because of the high
global prices we say ask those companies
to pay their fair share and that would
reduce those bills by 600 pounds so when
i'm talking to pensioners i was in
stevenage last week talking to
pensioners they weren't saying here we
want the revolution they were saying
here we're really worried about our bill
one of the pensioners said to me that
they keep their heating on 12 degrees
because they think if they put it higher
than that
they can't afford the bill and this you
know people having to make a choice
between heating and eating i mean in
21st century britain what people want to
know is is the labour party does it
understand those worries and the answer
that is yes we do have we got a
practical solution to put on the table
to reduce those bills by up to 600
pounds yes we have contrast that with
the government where there was just a
pathetic response which isn't going to
help very many people at all and this is
the thing that people are talking about
all over the country and the question in
the end is you know which party is on
your side and the labour party is on
your side i just want to conclude if we
can by talking about events in inverted
commas and around downing street carrie
johnson you seem to have suggested it
should be named if she is fined over
partygate and if that's the case should
we then expect to hear you know the next
time your wife gets a parking ticket
i think there's a huge difference
between um the situation of the wife of
the prime minister breaking the rules
made by the prime minister and any other
situation and i'm i'm not focusing on um
carrie here i actually do agree with the
general argument that families of
politicians shouldn't be dragged in but
and therefore i focus
well
rishi soon asks
again i agree i do agree with the
general proposition that
you know family members shouldn't be
brought into political arguments but so
far as the chancellor's wife is
concerned this is just a fundamental
question of principle here which is
is their household benefiting from money
made in russia when the government's put
in place sanctions
that is in the public interest for us to
have an answer to i'm not attacking um
their family
i don't agree with that way of doing
politics but i do want to know is the
chancellor's household the chancellor's
household
benefiting from money from a company
that's investing in russia when the
government is saying quite rightly
that nobody should be doing that
sanctions should be in place and we
should particularly in the dreadful
situation in ukraine frankly be doing
everything we can not just to
make life more difficult in russia but
to [ __ ] their ability to function so
it's not a personal attack i don't agree
with that i absolutely don't agree with
that but i do think that i would have
thought the chance would actually want
to come clean on this and say actually i
can be very very clear that my household
doesn't benefit from any money that's
come in any way from russia um during
this invasion of ukraine it's a simple
question i think you should just answer
it actually help his wife if he just
answered that question
um secure stamina we have to leave it
there because i have to admit it sounds
like the breakfast rush might be
starting just just over your shoulder
there secure stamina thanks very much
for joining us appreciate it
thank you
let's turn our attention to the war in
ukraine now and in a move which
threatens to push wholesale gas prices
even higher president putin said he will
cut gas supplies to europe unless
payments are made in the russian
currency the ruble from today france and
germany have dismissed the black demand
as blackmail well here are some of the
other developments this morning
after banning russian oil last month the
us is to open its own oil reserves next
month in a bid to bring down record
costs president biden ordering the
release of a million oil barrels a day
for six months
ukrainian authorities say that russia
has handed back control of the chernobyl
nuclear power plant the last russian
troops reportedly leaving earlier this
morning
the ministry of defence says that kiev
and cherniv have seen continued air
missile attack despite russian promises
to scale back
their assault on the cities
and the mlt also says the russia is
redeploying troops from georgia to
ukraine to make up for its casualties
they add it is highly unlikely russia
had been expecting to do this
it is the flattened suburb just a few
miles away from ukraine's capital
european has been constantly bombarded
by russian forces for more than a month
and with little or no access to water or
electricity many of its residents
haven't eaten for several days sky's
special correspondent alex crawford
witnessed the scale of the destruction
alongside the ukrainian military
the place is littered with unexploded
ordnance in playgrounds in residential
forecourts nowhere was off limits and
there was no mercy shown for europeans
residents
people obviously tried to pack their
cars to try and get out of here as the
shelling came in and you can see the
place is strewn with belongings as they
tried to get out but the shells were
coming in and hitting even the vehicles
as they tried to escape
and you can see alex's full report from
urpin a little later this morning on sky
news breakfast uh but before that let's
take a look at some of the day's other
headlines now
and the government will ban so-called
conversion therapy for gay and bisexual
people in england and wales but not for
trans people
it was initially announced that
ministers would not be fulfilling a
pledge to ban the practice
but downing street hastily backtracked
after facing retaliation from lgbt
groups and some mps
mps are to hold an inquiry into the
detention and release from iran of
zagari radcliffe and anush ashuri the
commons foreign affairs committee said
it would take evidence on how their
cases were handled by british officials
as part of a wider investigation into
state-level hostage situations
from today mps will see their pay
increase by more than 2 to 200 pounds a
year the independent parliamentary
standards authority that sets mp's pay
recommended the rise taking their annual
salary to 84 000 pounds both boris
johnson and secure stammer were against
the increase at a time when millions are
feeling the impact of rising prices
i will in the last few minutes on the
day that's seen millions plunged into
financial uncertainty as a result of
rising energy prices the policing
minister kit mulhaus defended the
chancellor's handling of the cost of
living crisis he told me rishi sunak is
trying to strike a balance between
supporting the public
and managing the needs of the economy
the chancellor is trying to do a very
difficult thing which is to balance the
requirements of the british people for
assistance at a time of need against the
long-term financial health of the whole
country right we we've just come through
a pandemic where we had to spend 400
billion plus to keep the economy on
track that work that he did has kept
hundreds of thousands if not millions of
people in work and kept you know them
going uh through one of the most
difficult things we've faced in this
country since the second world war that
was a massively challenging job and he
pulled it off uh with enormous skill and
dexterity of course he's in touch with
the problems of the british people and
that's why we brought in the measures
work that we've had but as he's said uh
just to think yesterday right that the
constraints of the national economy mean
that we can't solve every problem we
have to monitor the situation and
efficiently financially as we can to
help as many people as we can
uh well i also spoke with the leader of
the labour party secure stammer he was
well less than impressed with the
government's handling of the crisis
here's what he told me
oil and gas companies in the north sea
have made more profit than they expected
because global prices have been high
therefore we should have a windfall tax
on that and use it to reduce those
energy bills by up to 600 pounds for
those that need it most so there's a
very practical plan on the table the
only plan on the table quite frankly
we've also said of all the times for the
government to decide to impose more tax
in national insurance now is the wrong
time the government really needed to
step up in that spring statement last
week
they failed to do so and their response
is frankly pathetic on a very very
difficult day for millions and millions
of people
ali fortescue was looking in the wings
and listening into both of those
interviews i mean what have we learned
beyond the fact that clearly the
governments and the official opposition
are very different approaches to dealing
with the rise of
the rise in the cost of living well i
think we we heard the minister there
admitting that there's a problem that's
something the prime minister said this
week he said the cost of living is
running too high uh and we heard mult
house there saying prices are rising
significantly it is tough but as you
rightly asked him is this targeting the
right people is it getting to the people
that need it most he talked about the 1
billion pounds for council the ni
threshold rising but you're rightly
saying you know things like the fuel
duty cut that isn't going to help people
that actually are on the lowest income
we know that inflation is rising much
more quickly than benefits and i think
you know we could hear there and talking
to back bench mps you know there's a
real sense of expectation now that we
will see the chancellor going further
and we heard
the minister there saying that the
situation is being monitored closely he
said we have to think about what more we
may have to do so i think you get a
sense there that we might see the
chancellor going further labour clearly
spotting an opportunity um kierstama
there keen once again to talk about that
windfall tax on energy companies but as
you were rightly saying you know that's
not necessary that is a short-term thing
that's something you can do once it's
not necessarily going to solve the
problem in the long term he was talking
about the um their energy strategy of
course we're still waiting for the
government's energy strategy um but
again that's that's a kind of long
long-term plan we're not going to be
able to invest in nuclear straight away
so what are they actually going to do in
the medium term and i think that's a big
question for labour
but when we say
that the assistance is perhaps not being
targeted i mean we talked about this and
i talked about this in the interview
with kate malthus when you're talking
about national insurance kind of sorting
the threshold when you're talking about
fuel duty there are people at the very
bottom that that won't be assisted by
any of that so is it fair to say that
the government's assistance has very
much been focused on people in work well
there's certainly
analysis that suggests that
the majority of people that are going to
be helped aren't necessarily the people
at the very you know earning the very
least and as i say you know benefits are
being massively um outstripped by
inflation and it was interesting to hear
kia stammer you're really pushing him
there because if labor really are the
party of working people are they
actually going to commit to keep
benefits in line with inflation he said
that's something he's going to look at
um but he didn't actually confirm if
that was a policy that they were going
to be moving forward there but i think
that's something that labour are going
to keep facing a lot of pressure on yeah
i mean slightly too early in the
parliamentary cycle for that commitment
uh for now thanks very much ali um but
let's take you through the front pages
and it is no surprise that the cost of
learning crisis is on many of the fronts
uh april cruel day that's the headline
in the mirror consumers hit with a range
of price and tax hikes
then amount to what the paper calls the
worst attack on living standards
the metro leads with news of energy
company websites crashing as customers
trying to get their media ratings in
before they're hit by those big price
rises
the eye says that senior conservative
mps are accusing the chancellor of being
politically naive as national insurance
increases
the daily mail features a story about
prince andrew the paper says it's seen
court documents which show the royal has
been embroiled in a fraud case there is
no suggestion of any wrongdoing on his
part
and here is the times
it reports that britain is worried that
america france and germany will pressure
ukraine into a peace deal with russia
that will make too many concessions to
moscow
well a new humanitarian corridor was
meant to open in mario paul this morning
but in the last few minutes the besieged
city's mayor says that russian forces
are not allowing aid in
and that the city is very dangerous to
try and exit let's bring in our security
and defense editor deborah haynes who's
in the western ukrainian city of lev
deborah good to see you i mean i suppose
whilst we hope for those humanitarian
corridors to open up the bigger picture
is that we need to get some sort of
resolution to the crisis and the only
way resolution appears likely is through
some form of negotiated settlement it's
just what you have to give up to get
that settlement
yes that's been a question that has
eluded negotiators so far um here we are
more than a month into this war and
situations in cities like mario pole
that you were just talking about are
absolutely desperate yesterday there'd
been a glimmer of hope with the russian
side indicating they would allow
humanitarian aid in and evacuations out
and yet today like you said we're
hearing from an aide to the mayor of
that city saying that russian forces
aren't allowing this humanitarian aid
the two sides just don't seem to be able
to keep these attempts at ceasefires uh
in and around mariopol together and for
the people that are still left inside
that city it's absolutely desperate the
testimonies that
we're hearing from residents that have
managed to escape
and from images early on you'll remember
was a very brave associated press camera
team that were in the city and were able
to document the impact of the russian
bombardment on civilian infrastructure
including a maternity hospital there was
also uh that theater you'll remember
where they had the words children
written outside and yet it was struck by
a large uh russian attack uh the the
situation inside is is dire for those
left food supplies short energy supplies
very very low water running out that's
why humanitarian aid is so crucial and
in terms of the wider battle that's
going on across the country the
ukrainian president has said that he is
preparing for more battles ahead um in
the donbass area to the east around the
southern city of mariopol as it seems
that russia
which has failed in its objective to
take cities like here in kiev uh and and
around the north focusing more its
firepower uh towards the east that was
an area that had been heavily contested
for eight years the donbass region um by
russia
so-called separatists fighting ukrainian
forces uh now again this focus to try to
create what's described as a land
corridor from russia to crimea that
annexed territory that was taken by
russia back in 2014 so very serious
battles most likely ahead diplomacy
still continuing virtual talks are going
to be taking place today but as you said
it seems very unclear how the two sides
are going to be able to come up with a
compromise they could both agree to
deborah for now many thanks indeed
uh we're joined now on the programme by
ukraine's deputy health minister uh
alexi yaramenko uh minister it's great
to have you on the program this morning
and and and i wonder if we might start
with
uh what the matters closest to your
brief just how dire is the humanitarian
situation in parts of ukraine at the
moment
hello
um and so now uh we observe
unprecedented purity towards civil
inhabitants um as you see
from the news russian migration targets
its everyday residential areas social
infrastructure
as well as hospital with heavily missile
strikes
in
some region
the humanitarian corridors doesn't work
and
we cannot bring medicine water and food
to
our cities specifically marijuana
summer
chernygiev and
some other
areas on the
east
and
it's uh quite
it's very um
a
bad situation um and
what we really need is to open uh a
humane corridor to bring medicine to the
people in the hospitals
just in terms of the humanitarian aid
you're receiving i know that earlier
this week minister you said that you
know the humanitarian aid was
diminishing i mean where are you feeling
the pinch most particularly in terms of
that aid what more can the west do in
just at least the humanitarian area
first of all
we
appreciate all international support
from
countries and organizations that are
bringing
humanitarian medicines to ukraine we
already receive
more than six
thousand uh
200 2
600 tons of different medicine and
medical equipment
but
we need more because the number of
attack
attacks airstrikes are increasing and
we need uh
more
energetic antibiotics and aesthetics
internal fixation system
tell us just a little bit then about the
conditions inside some of those cities
that you have mentioned at mario paul
where we're looking at pictures from our
apron just now where the city is well
the suburb is pretty much entirely
demolished uh from inside mariupol
though however we understand that there
are still a number of people living at
civilians living inside the city do you
have a rough idea of numbers do you know
the conditions that they're living in
the
number is more than
one 000 people
but
we cannot get
medicine to this
to the marijuana for the last
36 days
it's me and that
situation are
hardly bad and
we actually don't we have a clear
pictures about the old humanitarian how
bad it's the humanitarian crisis there
but it's already
critical for the last weeks
before we let you go minister i do want
to ask of course there are negotiations
ongoing between the ukrainian government
representatives and and those from
russia
do you genuinely have any hope that a
negotiated settlement is possible given
what you have seen the russians do in
places like mario paul
uh thank you for your question uh but um
the comments from ukrainian side can
only be a president on this question
could come and president and uh some
people with
from a ministry of foreign affair uh i
cannot comment this
i will i will accept that answer alexis
thank you so much for joining us in the
program this morning really appreciate
it
thank you
now one of the organizers of the oscars
has claimed that police were prepared to
arrest the actor will smith after he
slapped the comedian chris rock live on
stage
the show's producer will packer said the
comedian spoke with police shortly after
the incident
it was the word they used in that moment
they said uh
we will go get him we are prepared we're
prepared to get him right now you can
press charges we can arrest him you have
they were laying out the options and as
they were talking chris was
he was being very dismissive of
those options he was like no i'm i'm
fine he was like no no no
and
even to the point where
i said i said rock let him let him
finish
now organisers of the qatar world cup
have hit back at criticism after the
president of the norwegian football
association condemned the country's pure
human rights record qatar is in the
spotlight today as it hosts the draw for
the group stages of the men's football
world cup our correspondent tom
parmenter is in doha and joins us now
good to see you tom i mean the war of
words has been going on for almost as
long as qatar has tried to host the
world cup it's going nowhere they will
be hoping that
the pomp and circumstance and all the
ceremony of the draw today might you
know serve as something of a lightning
rod
yeah this is the day that this
tournament the football of this
tournament starts to feel very real
indeed england are will be in pot one
they are among the top seeds they're
among the favorites for this tournament
and gareth southgate has said that they
are capable of getting to the final
they're capable of winning that final if
they are near perfect
and the players will be coming at this
tournament
fairly fresh because it will happen in
the middle of the season it's not going
to be the summer because it's simply too
hot here in qatar so it'll start on the
21st of november and finish with a world
cup final just over a week before
christmas so a very different feeling
world cup out here one of scotland wales
or ukraine will also be in the finals
but we won't know the uh results of
their playoff until june because of
course the conflict in ukraine has
postponed their playoffs
but that is a tantalising prospect could
this be gareth bale's big swan song in a
whale shirt or will the tartan army be
camping in the desert come november here
in doha the controversies around human
rights of the workers have built the
stadiums and of course this is a country
where it is illegal to be gay
we'll all be part of the mix and the
hosts here in qatar insist that everyone
is welcome and that promise will
undoubtedly be put to the test but the
big draw is happening around 5 p.m uk
time all the names in the hat there'll
be a group of death no doubt by the end
of the day there'll be all sorts of
possibilities they'll overcomplicate it
fifa always do but it is all happening
here in qatar and the focus will be very
much on who's facing who by the end of
later today
tom many thanks indeed
i will stick with the topic and get a
little bit more ahead of the draw i will
join now by the former head of the fa
mark palios mark great to have you on
the program this morning um i wonder if
we're going to be somewhat cheeky with
my first question here in your mind you
know what first attracted fifa to the
oil-rich arab nation you know with a
questionable human rights record it
couldn't have been money could it
well we know that it was it was awarded
in in um well pretty poor circumstances
uh first of all the whole process was
wrong i'm here they actually had two
world cups being voted for at the same
time so you immediately gave them the
opportunity to trade votes and the
question of trading votes and the
question of paying for votes uh always
surrounded the awarding of the the those
two world cups to russia and in a 2018
and to qatar i think if you look at it
you will see that there are 24 members
of exco who would have voted on that two
were excluded for reasons of uh bribery
and corruption uh and since that time of
the remaining twenty to fifty percent of
them eleven of them have been banned for
for uh for basically that as well so you
know you you you can say it was it this
was um
this was a tournament that was born in
controversy and has been mired in
controversy right the way through
did they have to go ahead with it though
mark i mean was there not an opportunity
for fifa to have exited stage left at
any point since qatar were awarded the
world cup
i i think if there was an opportunity
but it was a very difficult road to
travel because you almost certainly
would have got into um heavy legal
issues
and and whether fifa a first of all had
the appetite for that in the early days
um i i don't think they did and clearly
you know since then set blatter has gone
that partly as a consequence of what was
going on at the time and as the time
moved forwards it became less and less
easy for fifa to get out of it basically
contractually so i think that that's it
yes they certainly could have exited i
think but it would have been painful for
them but fifa aren't known for taking
sort of um
painful decisions i think and you know i
you saw it recently as well they they
weren't
immediately out of the traps as regards
the spon their response to what was
happening in ukraine to what extent
though by your reckoning have they
actually managed to to put their house
in order i mean there were some that
suggest you know
jenny and fentino
more of the same in terms of the the
corruption that we saw from set platter
i i think it's difficult to tell i mean
one of the things that um people talk
about governance and it's a very sort of
soft issue that they talk about it's
actually it's the hardest issue because
organizations are really sort of
an amalgamate the people that are in
there with their personal interests the
answers are i don't know and time will
tell as regards fifa
but is the governance of fifa better i
think it's probably slightly better um
but you know at the end of the day you
judge people by what they do and um you
know that's yet to be seen and equally
you know al fawadi who is the guy who's
really responsible for delivering the
world cup in qatar has said many things
uh and you know
he said the right things but at the end
of the day the proof of the pudding will
be in the eating and we'll see what
happens uh when they when when the
tournaments run
do you know what mark shall we just for
once we actually talk about the football
i mean who do you want to see yeah who
do you want to see in england's draw i
mean there are some there are some there
are some very interesting possibilities
that could arise out of the draw today
yeah i i look we're in we're in part one
you can't do better than that and you're
qualifying
and they'll then go to part two and if
you're looking at part two who don't you
want to see well i'm very much of the
belief that at the end of the day if you
want to win the world cup uh you've got
to beat anybody so um but you it would
be nice to get your foot hold in the
tournament and to grow into the
tournament and therefore make it as easy
as possible i think you're looking at
part two the only team i don't want and
maybe that's because of my age uh is the
german team that i think they they um
they won nine out of ten and they're
qualifying that so that they're not in
bad form um so if if other than that i'm
fairly relaxed because i think this
english england team is a consequence
not just of um you know where we are
today it's a consequence of many years
um since we put in the the
the four corner model uh the fa put in
the four corner model in 2007. and if it
takes about 10 years to rattle through
the through the uh
through the system so 10 years later in
2017 we were the under 17 world
champions the 19 european champions and
the other 20 world champions
so you have this sort of conveyor belt
of more gifted players coming through
and we also have you know that what you
do need is those those relatively
experienced players like harry kane and
maguire and and whilst he's criticized
at times maguire you know we've got
we've got one of the best defensive
records of the international teams so i
think we've got a very good chance
uh mark the team to watch scotland my
that's my show and i'm going to stick to
it uh mark it's good to have you on the
program this morning do you think yeah
uh well let's bring in jackie beltran
who i know has had over the past few
weeks a thing or two to say about what's
been going on in qatar we had a kind of
a microcosm of it there you know we're
all excited about the football but we
can't forget the stuff that's happening
not in the margins but literally outside
and inside the stadiums
yeah absolutely and uh qatar were called
out yesterday very publicly by the
norwegian fa and they seemed sort of a
bit disgruntled and uncomfortable that
they would be criticized still at this
point you know on the verge of the world
cup and you know the norwegian president
said you know it's unacceptable they
were given it in the first place but you
know things like workers rights haven't
been addressed enough um
6 000 or more than 6 000 workers have
died during the construction of these
brand new eight stadiums for the world
cup and although qatar say you know we
have addressed criticisms we have
improved their conditions we have paid
compensation to the families of the
workers who've died um
others are saying well yeah you know but
you are the ones under scrutiny you are
the ones hosting a world cup you may
have better rights for your workers than
your neighboring countries but that
should be the case because you are the
ones under the spotlight and many
countries believe that not enough has
been done not enough has been done uh
for gay people you know and even god
southgate has said you know it is a
shame that some england fans will feel
uncomfortable going to this world cup
jackie many thanks indeed